Phoenix is looking a little cleaner
today the Democrat City forced to clear
out a massive 15 block homeless
encampment known as The Zone after
resident sued a court ordering them to
move thousands of people out of the area
along with tents trash and makeshift
structures it took them $20 million to
get it done but it seems like it was
worth it a majority of the homeless have
reportedly gone straight to City housing
and business owners are
thrilled it's a relief and a half and we
are now able to open and you can see
there's parking people are not afraid to
come down here and uh and I think it's
going to be a renaissance for the whole
neighborhood Greg you talk about this
we've talked about this a lot on this
show it seems like a de I'm glad de a
Leader's done it happens to be a
Democrat is this the right thing and
should this be a model for the country
definitely and it also seemed pretty
easy to do there were no riots they got
up and they left where did they go
presumably some kind of shelter why
wasn't it done sooner sooner what's the
lesson for the other cities that all you
have to do is decide to do it
politicians will tell you what they want
to do but they never decide to do
anything unless they got skin in the
game and apparently they got sued right
the city got sued so the theory is Dems
only act on behalf of its taxpaying
law-abiding citizens when they think
they're going to lose an election or
they're going to lose money DP you have
thoughts on this exactly so the couple
that brought the suit have a restaurant
and basically the they were at their
wits end they had called the city so
many times they call their Congressman
nothing's being done they finally file a
lawsuit and it did take them a while it
took them several months to actually get
this done they started last the
beginning of May or so to to try to get
this done they had to have it done by
November 30th I'm glad that they did it
other cities should absolutely do it but
imagine you've paid your taxes every
year and the only way to get something
done is by suing yeah the city you have
to hire lawyers you have to do all
that's ridiculous the city should have
done this anyway and this is a good
warning it's a good opportunity but I
think also a warning for other cities
get ahead of it do what the people are
expecting which is do not allow
homelessness to take over your city
template for the rest of the country yes
when I was in Los Angeles where I stayed
I didn't see a single homeless person
yet Harold when I drove to LAX I saw
quite a few of them when you're at 69th
in Park Avenue here you don't see a lot
of homeless people go 20 blocks south
and a little bit to the West oh you'll
see some tents Harold same thing with
Mar this Vineyard no no no you can't
have migrants there can't so certain
places you're allowed to have migrants
certain places you're not and Greg's
right where there's a will there's a way
if people a certain type of person wants
them maybe a person with money wants
them out they'll get out and they'll get
out like that Kaye what are your
thoughts yeah this is tied to the Border
crisis look in San Francisco when you
have the FBI going from tent to tent
looking for Honduran fenol dealers we've
got a problem in this country the n9th
circuit ruled it is cruel and unusual
ual punishment to have an anti- camping
ordinance without providing temporary
shelter liberal 9th circuit needs to be
overturned because this is a travesty
hey everyone I'm Emily compano catch me
and my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye
mckin on outnumbered every weekday at 12
p.m. Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights